vous venez d'entendre l'homme qui plus
que tout autre est responsable de la
crise politique économique et sociale
que traverse notre pays
cet homme a été pendant six ans premier
ministre du général de gaulle et chef de
cette majorité qui sans vous consulter
rend rien décider de tout ce qui
concerne votre avenir
le bilan de cette gestion il est
écrasant mais vous le connaissez par
votre situation même d'aujourd'hui à
chacun de vous l'enjeu de cette élection
présidentielle cela aurait dû être de
savoir si maintenant il est possible à
la france de se choisir un autre avenir
est à côté des deux candidats de droite
qui de plus en plus disent la même chose
et défendent la même politique au point
qu'il sent accuse réciproquement
en face de ces deux candidats de droite
la grande question c'était de savoir si
ce soir vous auriez pu avoir en face de
vous un candidat unique de la gauche
j'ai pour ma part avec tout le courant
qui se bat sur les solutions socialiste
lutter autant que possible pour parvenir
à une candidature réellement socialistes
autour de laquelle l'ensemble de la
gauche aurait pu se rassembler mais cela
n'a pas dépendu de nous est il
responsable de cette situation vous les
connaissez c'est une fraction c'est un
plan de la et ses filles ou sous la
conduite de monsieur de fer qui a décidé
qu'on en arriverait là
est cette division si elle nous a déçus
ne m'a pas pour ma part beaucoup surpris
car elle a des raisons et nous en
reparlerons d'ailleurs car nous sommes
amenés à nous revoir n'est-il pas vrai
et il s'agit là du problème le plus
difficile que la gauche française et a
abordé dans les prochaines années
mais je voudrais aujourd'hui en prendre
un seul exemple si la gauche éclater si
elle se meurt c'est qu'elle n'a rien à
dire
et si elle n'a rien à dire aujourd'hui
tout entière c'est que devant les plus
gras des événements récents elle a
hésité ou s'est dispersé vous vous
souvenez il y a un an tout juste de
cette extraordinaire mouvement à travers
lequel des millions de travailleurs
ouvriers mensuel car paysans aussi
étudiants et enseignants fonctionnaires
même posé la question de la situation
qui leur est faite
ce fut un mouvement un peu chaotique mal
organisés avec bien sûr des actes
démesuré mais c'était surtout une
immense espérance et c'était aussi les
problèmes de notre avenir à tous posé
pour la première fois à l'ensemble du
pays
en face de cela il y a eu dans la gauche
tout ce qu'on a voulu
il ya eu ceux qui n'ont rien compris
vous chercheriez vainement ce qu'a dit
monsieur de faire à l'époque car il n'a
rien dit il ya eu ceux qui délibérément
ont cherché à limiter à amoindrir la
signification du mouvement à le ramener
à des revendications qui ne posaient pas
les problèmes du pouvoir dans notre
société notre conception à nous était
autre c'est qu'à cette occasion la
france prenait conscience et chacun de
vous de l'ensemble des difficultés des
problèmes que la résoudre pour assurer
son avenir
aujourd'hui chez nous les trois quarts
des paysans s'interroge sur le destin
qu'on leur prépare sur la place qui sera
la leur dans ce pays vers un très grand
nombre d'ouvriers de mensuel de
technicien 2/4 savent que leur emploi
est menacé un certain parce qu'il n'y a
pas de réponse au changement des
techniques et parce qu'on ne prépare
rien l'université qu'avait créé la
grande bourgeoisie à son image et pour
organiser la continuité de sa domination
l'université est en pleine crise
la moitié de nos régions stagne
certaines même dépérissent ceux des
peuples sans qu'on y prépare rien pour
assurer véritablement un avenir
d'expansion et de développement complet
pour chacun et puis plus gravement
peut-être notre monnaie même est très
menacé menacé par cette spéculation
absurde devant laquelle vous l'avez vu
on dépend de tout de n'importe quoi
d'une rumeur du climat c'est la monnaie
météorologie quel système absurde jamais
la démonstration ne nous en avait été
faite avec autant de clarté
alors tous ces problèmes il appelle à
nos yeux des solutions de type
socialiste
et puis il en est d'autres qui viennent
de se poser plus récemment ce que je
viens de citer ce sont des problèmes
économiques et sociaux on pourrait
croire qu'il suffit de bien gérer pour
les résoudre
mais plus récemment se trouve posé le
problème même du pouvoir
deux exemples ces jours derniers à
l'instant même un groupes financiers
étrangers essayent de prendre le
contrôle d'une des plus importantes de
nos sociétés sidérurgiques
le groupe schneider et le gouvernement
qui se veut libéral qui se veut
capitaliste hésite tout de même sur la
formidable démission que représenterait
l'abandon à d'autres du pouvoir de
décider de l'avenir d'un grand nombre de
nos travailleurs et puis en même temps
une équipe de journalistes qui pourtant
ne défendez pas nos idées
loin s'en faut faites aussi une grève
importante parce qu'elle veut exiger de
contrôler ce qui est fait de son travail
de limiter le droit absolu du
propriétaire à faire ce qu'il en veut
c'est là la question du pouvoir qui est
posée elle l'est dans toutes nos
entreprises agricoles industrielles ou
de services
elle l'est par tout le mouvement
syndical c'est aujourd'hui le problème
du pouvoir qui est le problème de
l'avenir de la france
ce problème du pouvoir j'ai compris peu
à peu que seul le socialisme lui
apportait une solution mais qu'est ce
que c'est aujourd'hui que le socialisme
dans une situation comme la nôtre dans
un pays développé malcommode il n'y a
pas de modèle
il faut donc de l'imagination il faut
réinventer
c'est l'objet de la solution socialiste
que je vous décris aujourd'hui au nom de
notre courant le socialisme c'est
d'abord un combat
regardez d'ailleurs le peu de sécurité
que nous avons aujourd'hui dans la
société française
ces nationalisations qui nous garantisse
contre les dégâts des crises économiques
ou au moins une partie d'entre eux la
sécurité sociale les congés payés la
suppression des zones de salaire même
que de longues queues de dures grève
il a fallu pour les imposer et cela
continuera
c'est partout et toujours la lutte qui
arrachent et la loi légalise après voilà
pourquoi et comment le socialisme est un
combat c'est un combat dans deux
perspectives
la première perspective c'est que la
société contrôler ses propres affaires
et ne laisse pas ce soin aux intérêts
des hommes de profits il est
inadmissible qu'un petit nombre
d'industriels de banquiers de grands
capitalistes décide de nos affaires s'en
rendre compte le moins du monde à qui
que ce soit et en fonction de leur seul
profit pour arriver à ce résultat il
faudra nationaliser certains secteurs il
faudra transformer bien des choses
la seconde perspective
c'est quand même temps et c'est là que
la perspective est nouvelle
par rapport à d'autres sociétés c'est
quand même temps chacun de nous chacun
de vous
suisse dans son entreprise dans sa
commune dans sa région
connaître discuter puis contrôler les
décisions qu'il subit les décisions qui
façonnent fabrique petit à petit ses
conditions d'existence
voilà la seconde perspective alors cela
conduirait à développer tout un
programme
et c'est ce que je ferai au cours de ces
différentes soirées mais de tout cela
découle d'abord trois objectifs
principaux qui entraîne les autres
ces trois objectifs principaux le
premier concerne l'état l'état c'est
énorme machine que vous connaissez
d'ailleurs cette machine où on attend à
tous les guichets pour rencontrer au
bout du guichet quelqu'un qu'on ne
connaît pas qui de toute façon ne
décidera pas car celui qui décide n'est
pas là et lui vous ne serez jamais s'il
est informé de votre problème
reconquérir l'état le démocratiser le
décentraliser faire que ceux dont dépend
notre vie quotidienne soit décidée dans
la commune et dans la région sous notre
contrôle
faire ensuite que l'état central se
borne à orienter d'économie à préparer
l'avenir c'est le premier des objectifs
du socialisme le second concerne
l'entreprise
le lieu de travail quelle qu'en soit la
nature agricole industriel n'importe et
là l'essentiel c'est de mettre fin à la
monarchie patronales les travailleurs
aujourd'hui seront éduqués organisé
compétents ils peuvent peser sur leur
décision les travailleurs ouvriers
mensuel techniciens cadres tous doivent
pouvoir discuter l'embauchent comme le
salaire le licenciement comme la
formation on peut d'ailleurs changé de
président de la république ou changer de
maire il faut que l'on puisse aussi
changer de patron et c'est le deuxième
des objectifs du social
le troisième concerne notre système
d'enseignement d'éducation permanente
d'information et de culture
vous le connaissez bien il a été
fabriqué par une toute petite couche
sociale par une classe très limité et la
haute bourgeoisie pour
gan is et la continuité de sa domination
il faut transformer cela et faire que
tout ce système par l'éducation
permanente comme l'information et la
culture permettent d'abord à chacun de
mieux connaître son propre métier de s'y
perfectionner dans changer aussi souvent
que le changement des techniques
l'exigent
il faut surtout aussi que ce système
permet à chacun de comprendre la société
dans laquelle il vit de discuter le sort
qui lui est fait de peser dessus de le
contrôler et de jouer pleinement son
rôle est de prendre ses responsabilités
dans la société
voilà le troisième objectif du
socialisme
ces objectifs sont considérables ils
sont très importants
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai aussi que
quand vous allez voter vous engagerez la
france pour longtemps
aujourd'hui que la gauche est à refaire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'elle ou il
faut qu'elle retrouve quelque chose à
dire
vous n'avez rien de plus important à
faire que de reconstruire cette gauche
autour du projet socialiste
ne vous laissez pas compromettre ou
impressionné par le combat que se
livrent des hommes de droite vous seriez
perdant de toute façon c'est la même
politique
aujourd'hui la tâche consiste à se
rassembler autour de la solution
socialiste à reconstruire autour d'elle
une gauche puissante
ainsi nous préparerons efficacement
notre avenir c'est le sens de ma
candidature comme c'est le sens de votre
vote
[Musique]